the u.s reported more than 99 thousand
new coronavirus cases friday more than
any country has ever reported
in a single day the new covid caseload
over the past three days is around
262 thousand case numbers are rising in
44 of the 50 states health officials are
especially concerned
about infections in key midwestern
battleground states
like iowa michigan and wisconsin as
adriana diaz reports these states
highlight
how political differences have affected
efforts to control the virus
it's the final push before election day
in wisconsin
a state all too familiar with political
division
one key point of contention this year
the country's coronavirus response
this has affected this community in very
very profound ways
you know we've lost a lot of good people
dr manar al-shahiri treats covet
patients at
two green bay wisconsin hospitals both
of which are near capacity
he's concerned about making progress
against the virus
saying public health policy has become
political
we are flaunting masking we're debating
basic effective measure you know i know
this is a very emotive
topic just stop look at the data look
around you
a new york times analysis looked at the
top 20 metro areas with the greatest
number of new cases relative to
population
and 10 were in wisconsin in two months
our seven day average has increased by
more than 500 percent
democratic governor tony evers says he's
not considering another lockdown
the state's republican-led legislature
has challenged his previous public
health orders
honestly it's just breathtaking we're in
a very difficult situation here we
should be pulling together instead of
pushing apart another concern for the
midwest dropping temperatures
forcing people indoors especially during
upcoming holiday gatherings
former fda commissioner scott gottlieb
spoke on face the nation
my view is the inflection point is going
to be thanksgiving i think it's going to
be unmistakable what's happening at that
point
the u.s could potentially hit a sobering
and scary milestone this week a daily
record of more than 100 000 cases
as we mentioned on friday we hit 99 300
cases which was the biggest single day
increase we've seen so far
and at least 14 states have broken their
own single day records
in the past three days tony all right
adriana thank you very much